what's the deal with airplane
peanuts from mind-blowing mentalists
oh two hilarious one liners sugar Shan
Ali what do you think about this guy
I've always been insecure about my neck
but I feel
like these are the best podcast moments
from October starting off with Jimmy
Carr on your mom's house Ron and I I
took him to a basketball game so he's
like so where you going and I was like
well I'm starting the European tour he's
like like like London I go no no like
all of Europe he was like really and I
go yeah he goes like where's your first
show I go Budapest hungry and he was
like Budapest I go yeah he goes people
are coming I go yeah it's sold out you
know CI the whole night yeah oh yeah the
whole night he was like we just sitting
there watching the game he'd go
Budapest there people going in Budapest
I was like yeah man and then he was I
find that thing of like the more obscure
place you go as well yeah that's so
weird so like if you play in New York
I'm doing carigi Hall later in the year
and they'll have a great time but
everyone at that show had other options
that night they had 50 options so many
great options right they like I could
have gotone the Knicks game genely want
to go thanks for being here sometimes
when I play Budapest they go you're very
lucky to have me here
yeah there's nothing else going on this
week yeah yeah and to your point
remember when Michael Jackson was so out
of fashion in America and then he would
go over to Eastern Europe and they're
like Michael we love you like well yeah
because yeah fuing communist country
nobody's coming here post because we
haven't heard the
allegations that too Michael Jackson rip
yes do you remember great man did sing
did a little dancing Dan remember the
mar I do a brilliant Michael Jackson
impersonation I just need a small kid
that can keep a
secret can we you know our our boys just
left if we went out in those waves a
little bit farther would have been a
Rescue 911 of me calling 911 that Tim D
just got swept out to see that would
have been like they would this would
have rejoiced gav would have had like a
glass of wine Palestine and Israel
ceasefire yeah that would be amazing
hostages are releas everything would be
great they Towers build back one by one
everybody loves it I want to add
something more please please do okay so
in the Philippines did you know that we
also have our own
KKK
wow I did not know thank you I did out
of my nose that was insane give me a
napkin yeah yeah yeah so um yeah give me
another one cuz that's not really a beef
Oh I thought that's my my one of my big
comedy beefs I mean what's uh what's his
name I mean ory Adams was rude to me but
that's like kind of his thing you know
he was a super dick to me I wouldn't
expect nothing less but are you you go
with now I'm not but he doesn't know it
uh call he he has a lot of hidden beefs
I'm going to call him right now well no
he won't remember I don't look at if you
want so so hey so what I'm saying it's
not really a beef it is a if I call him
right now but you don't want to do it he
doesn't what maybe I don't understand
what beef is but for me a beef is
something silently that I hold inside no
I think a beef is two two entities who
don't like each other describe one of
yours so no no no I have then I have no
beefs it's just all one-sided oh they're
all in your head single sided beef
inside you have resentment resentment
yes right I don't then I don't have any
beef but you you don't have like I have
so many beefs I bet you do yeah yeah I'm
beef man yeah yeah yeah yeah wow so what
rank your top two beefs top three beefs
well they're generally against Asians
other Asians you know I mean Asian hate
guy over it's Mongolian
beef so it's beef with broccoli
broccoli Kanye fired some trademarks uh
filed some trademarks filed yeah sorry
filed some trademarks for use
yws does anybody know we don't know but
it's fire why is it fire I don't know
it's fire we know it's fire maybe he's
just from Philly yo use guys yeah use
guys do you think that it's possible
that
Kanye okay Kanye has this thing about
him where like even though you're like H
he's so [__] annoying he'll do things
that make you laugh right there's this
thing about him that is undeniably like
Charming okay even though he's annoying
and can say the worst [__] he can also
just say something in an instant that
makes you just start laughing he got
that Trump thing yeah he does yeah okay
do you think people with that level of
charm and likeability they're not
actually sociopaths they just know that
whatever trouble they get themselves
into they can get themselves out of in a
heartbeat so they stop worrying about
what they say cuz they know it's like a
hot chick it's like I I I can be [__]
but like you're going to me you know
what I mean like crazy is I do a podcast
with a guy like
that it's really crazy actually you
think about it that's the greatest
compl I can I be honest I had a uh I
wanted to talk about this I had a uh I I
had a leis situation at a hotel you just
had a stroke trying to get that sentence
I did what is up I had a louw situation
at the hotel this weekend got your dick
sucked you were the man what happened
started started free coffee started
internet getting your knob robbed I
started seven
companies so great is just in the work
center and some guy's like I got to
print out directions and he's like get
the [__] out of here I'm the only person
who uses the
business this is said was like a relic
of the paste loues and they're going B
sell I got to print my airline
to how am I going to know without my
directions from MTH Quest dude Business
Center you look at you're like what is
going why is it exist anymore I don't
know just six computers that nobody ever
uses ever it's for people who just got
out of jail to email their Falcon family
member what's a driveway situation
driveway driveway and garage paved paved
yeah do they park the car in the garage
one can fit in the garage the other
one's the uh the lounge area for me and
my dad smoke s wait the other the other
part yeah so is a two car garage two
doors two car garage one car fits you
park one car in there and then what are
you guys sitting on when you're having
your garage heaters and was this set up
like you were high school kids like is
there a couch in there and [__] yeah my
dad has a sign in there that says I I
live in the garage I sleep in the house
oh
man that's the Chill Spot for me and is
your dad retired now is he still working
as a retired yeah okay is he working or
is he just chilling he's working all
right I don't think he'll ever stop
working I wish what's he doing now he's
security all right there you go that's a
fun that's a good retired top job where
is he security at he works at a school
no kidding and like a concert venue in
the summertime there you go mhm he went
to the Snoop Dog concert this weekend
this summer Snoop it's me guard dog
senior yeah we are
related the dog family I didn't even I
didn't even make that connection why is
this the thing on podcast now is people
bragging about making money but that's
their entire identity yeah I mean
because the whole thing is his his whole
thing is that he'll if you pay him he'll
teach you how to make that much money so
his whole thing is like oh damn I just
made1 that's obviously it yeah then then
you can just be like oh [__] I want to
make you can pay him you pay me $2,000 a
month I'll get he's like I mean it's
just not even a question I'll get you to
make $100,000 a month so just selling
fit once he trains you in fitness
programs and like once you get jacked
everybody's going to hire you yeah for
real you're going to become a CEO yeah
literally think about it think how many
CEOs are jacked jacked and detached most
of them you got to get jacked and
detached most of them are [__]
bodybuilders huge big time yeah I mean
dude Tim Cook swole Jack Elon Musk swole
Jack Zuckerberg Zuck doing Jiu-Jitsu now
though which is a good thing for them to
work on yeah as if their bodyguards
aren't going to kill anybody that ever
touches them it's time for them to focus
strictly on hand toand combat where the
other guy doesn't have a weapon are is
Zak and uh if only Abraham Lincoln had
learned
Jiu-Jitsu he would have survived the
assassination he could have survived the
fall from being shot he could have
rolled he could have rolled into away
gone straight to an ankle lock on the
ground shot for the legs of Booth Booth
was dealing with the broken leg
afterwards too could got yeah he jumped
off the balcony he shot him and then
jumped down onto the stage and shattered
his leg it's kind of it's kind of he
like you six Emperor
tyrannis it was like what a dork but my
mom didn't know [__] she still really
doesn't understand at all really no she
understands that she has a house now she
has a house D when when I tell you when
I told her like hey things are going
really well I want to make sure you're
taken care of you don't have any bills
to pay for the rest of your life like I
want to get you a house
she was like Oh that's oh that's I'm so
lucky thank thank you so much whatever 9
days go by right I get a call did you
get the link that I sent you I go what
you send she like oh I sent I sent a
Zillow link I oh you've been looking for
houses okay fantastic let me take a look
at
it Tom my mom lives in an apartment yeah
that she smokes in the bathroom of
uhhuh she sends me a link for a nine
bedroom
$3.5 million house with horse stables
what I go you don't even know n people
who's going to live in this [__]
house yeah this is crazy she goes well
in case any any of you guys want to like
come home for the holidays or something
come home for the holay I haven't come
over the holidays in 6 years you think
I'm going to go when I have to fly into
Atlanta airport are you out of your
[__] mind you're out of your mind and
I go I go the the horse stables she goes
well that's why it's so expensive I go
who who horses she goes well you know
I've always wanted want horses I go yeah
and I've always wanted my real dad back
but like sometimes you have to be
logistic about these kind of things my
mom is 48 years old she's always injured
always she has um she has what's it
called vertigo to where she can barely
stand upright for most of the time I'm
like you're going to learn to take care
of horses at 48 years old and you're
going to do it after who's going to buy
the horse so you bought the house in the
barn bought a different house way less
expensive version way less bedrooms yes
four bedrooms for her and her boyfriend
to live in by themselves she goes oh I
got to she goes well I got to have a
pool for who she goes well I've always
wanted she goes I I want a pool I go
I've known you for 27 years never seen
your hair wet never seen you s I've
never seen you take a bath hilarious
I've never seen my mom anywhere near
water and all of a sudden she's like I
don't want a house unless it has a pool
that's crazy so [__] ridiculous did
you get the pool no I didn't get the
pool I got a house with a lake behind it
a big pond behind it and she still goes
yeah and they said the land is totally
okay to install a pool if we want I go
Mom I love you but you're white trash
you're going to take this above ground
pool like an adult and enjoy it that's
amazing dude it's amazing that you're
like I'm going to things are all right
and she's like here's a $3 and5
million like are you out of your mind I
you're not getting a better house than
what I would get for myself that's the
guy who say look at how he comes into
Stage we serly have to come onto stage
one day like this we ever do a live P
babe I swear to God so this is what
we're doing oh my
God
we it looks like
CGI I get some people going could you
imagine him breaking his leg on the
intro wait wait look they weren't
cheering
before and then they literally just it
was like look at the look at the crowd I
kind of want to see this guy I know that
that would that looks like like
literally like like Lim biscuit at like
wble Stadium I heard he does Gangham
Style like five or six times in a row
like he just constantly just does it and
they're cry it's his opener and his
closer for sure I saw settle down no I
van yo did you see right before it went
he went a little oh my God this guy's a
legend legend bro that dude dude he
might be the most famous person in the
world wow his physicality is
he's the most famous person that is 1
million people look example with the
cowboy best on what morons we are we're
like oh maybe Michael Jackson maybe
Beyonce oh it's s congratulations you're
the most famous person in the world I
mean obviously he kept going and we
didn't hear about it right how is that
possible dude is that all Gangam Style
right there or do he have like now like
discography that we don't know about as
it's the 11th most viewed video on
YouTube 4.9 billion views is that more
than salsa
windfall
Jo um let's suppose I was Japanese yeah
according to you the best kind yeah you
know and I'm in a CH a Japanese interman
Camp you know when San Francisco yeah
yeah and you're a guard mhm right at
this Japanese interman Camp yeah and I
come up to you and I wouldn't have an
accent because no they were American I
yeah yeah so but hey man
can you can you get me a sandwich would
you get me a sandwich I'm being 100%
honest with you I would I would be the
guy you spit in it I no I I would be the
same guy I am back then as I am today I
love this country I bleed red white and
blue I defend this country in anything I
can so I work for my country so you
can't get out you're in the cell if if
the President Eisenhower president uh
Roosevelt told me you need to stay in
the cell you stay in the cell but you're
also human but but I said to you hey
dude what's your name name back then no
like in the in the scenario oh um uh my
name um you're not good at improv huh no
no no no no my Henderson myth Henderson
murf Henderson murf
Henderson Mur I don't I I don't need
your last name Mur murf murf yeah I'm
Tok to hey to to yeah yeah so what I
would do you just call me to though no
but what I would do and I and know but I
would what I would say to you is is like
to uh MV I'm to check it out I was born
here correct
I mean I no I I have my birth
certificate here yeah Sharp Hospital
that's it I see it it's right see it
right there to to yeah read it yeah to
yeah you have it on
seaweed well there's a little seaweed
Emoji after Tok to anyway so I'm like I
so so MV I was born here I own a little
you know a farming I I I'm a farmer
right you know what I mean and I I
haven't done anything wrong in my life
why am I in this prison well it's to to
i i i to I understand how you and your
family must feel I see them sitting on
the floor right now and and I know is
that a that's you you didn't provide for
any chairs it's that an Asian thing you
know I mean sitting on the floor no but
I was told that we were told by our
government that the Japanese don't need
furniture and they don't need they sit
on the floor we we we love them though
but just by anyway let's move on so so
so I I and I'm sad for you but I'm you
know I work for for the United States
and you have to stay in here but I will
go get you a sandwich I'll get you a and
I would come back with your sandwich and
I would have Chopsticks there for you to
eat your sandwich with no I I use it
with my hands as well I was under the
impression that you guys only use
chopsticks if it was like sea like it
was a sushi or something you know but or
rice anyway yeah but I know that you MV
and you and Dango what's his name your
friend oh Arie Dango yeah yeah Arie
Dango Dango you guys go to strip clubs
late at night yes we do can I just sneak
me out I want to go uh to I have come on
yeah bring to yeah yeah yeah yeah would
you yes yes I I could sneak out to go
the with you and Archie I can go to the
[__] you go to the strip club now I
have no money because they probably take
your money away yeah would you give me
dollar bills for I would let you I would
let you have a little I would let you
have a little bit of fun and then if you
say can I come yeah you let me come yeah
because I'd want to see what at that
point in my life I'd want to see what
Japanese come looks like sence science
thing yeah like when you know pretty
much similar I think similar it you come
it's all white with a little red dot in
the middle like the flag little
blood yeah there's a little dot in there
yeah yeah yeah that's funny that's
funnyes yeah yeah but um this is a
condition I have but anyway um can you
imagine being a Japanese video game
music composer hold on yes and there's
no bar you're making the M you're making
the music for [__] Mario was their
boss listen up
Japanese you're making the music oh for
Mario
they all love smoking they love smok
they do love smoking they love smoking
they love attitude and smoking and being
bossed around Jack also you know there's
a part of Japan where everyone dresses
like Dice Clay oh dude have you never
been to uh uh uh uh Harajuku have you
never been there haruku Harajuku do you
not know this is this the Greaser Town
Harajuku is like the cool hip uh young
funky fashionable like really kind of
like really really kind of out there
doing their thing and they usually and
yeah in Japan they take a culture they
always have like a cultural moment and
they all become it like they have a goth
they had a goth time in Harajuku they
had like a hipster time they also had a
skater time big big pants Asian goth
jinko jeans Asian goth extra scary to me
because it's very the ring but they
smile a lot what was the ring what was
the ring except a goth Asian it was a
goth Asian she had a hair in front of
her face beautiful hair great hair came
out of the TV didn't matter HD standard
D that Demon's going to get you I don't
know I'm doing it Joe Biden that was
Biden very good here's my uh Melania
Trump it's me I'm a model I have big
perky one big beautiful perky breast
that's my perfect and let me do I can do
Jared Kushner his son-in-law yeah ready
[Laughter]
yeah can I go to the bathroom
now that's every day of his life yeah no
he can't go they got him trapped let's
go back to the dog poo can we move on
from the pool no because when you were a
kid right we didn't have to pick it up
right wasn't half the fun when you were
a kid in the 70s and the maybe even the
in the 80s too I don't think they
started to pick up the Poo thing till
the late 90s right or the mid90s you
just stood there and watched the dog
said hello to everybody like yeah we
didn't you just left it and half the fun
of being a kid was maneuvering down the
sidewalk so you didn't step on it it was
kind of like that Billy Jean you know
the video Michael Jackson did where the
the tiles light up and he's like Billy
Jean Ste with us it was like Sid
stepping loafs of
poo and what I used to love is every now
and then you'd get the loser that didn't
see it and you just see the trail of
ghostly poo Footprints all the way down
the sidewalk until they slowly got
lighter and lighter awful if you had
grooves in the bottom of your speakers
because then it gets in the groove and
you know you're in the house and it's
like what stinks what stinks yeah let me
see your shoe
Roy you have to get a stick go outside
get a stick and clean out every
Groove and even worse you know sometimes
shoes had a little heel and then there
was the arch and then the bottom of the
shoe yes sometimes people would step in
that and get the whole that whole always
like what stinks what stinks yeah I had
a guy stay over at my house once okay I
was living in Glendale this is before
the poaw and he must have stepped in
some didn't realize it and he was
visiting and I was in a little tiny
Apartments when I first moved to
Hollywood I said hey you can sleep on
the couch and he was cool with he slept
there and so he went to bed we came home
at night and he went to the couch and he
didn't take his shoes off he just kind
of plopped down we must have been
drinking beer or something and when I
walked out in the morning to the living
room I was like what the did this guy
crap his pants and there was like dog
poo all over the arm of my couch and I
go dude you stepped in poo and he like
oh
man I can't stop saying hunka hunka what
are you looking for no my costume is
Adam Sandler's
um costume yeah do you remember it which
one I'm crazy Master
guys oh my God
crazy that's what I how do you slack
your face perfectly like he does is that
is that a bird it's a plane it's
superglue man super glue man I can stick
to anything wow wow wow do the skeleton
guy oh look at me I have a skeleton
girlfriend isn't that
crazy wo
what wow Adam can I tell you my favorite
movie of yours is Jack and Jill I'm not
doing Adam anymore oh damn it I've got
to get the word to him that I've seen
that movie in theaters twice I love it
you really like it you're going to read
his mind okay how about it okay okay do
this shake hands it's getting weird I
don't know freeze right there freeze
right there just till it gets awkward
okay Jordan look this way you're my
Witnesses you are not going to guess
what's in his head cuz I don't want to
know sure you're not going to guess a
name a number a celebrity I've done it
all the Lita Express that was insane
it's going to be watch this if I reach
over and I brush this across Sam's
healthy head of hair oh yeah you're
going to feel something right there in
your hair if I poke his knee you'll
swear to God I poked your knee whatever
he feels you feel like like oh finally
you'll come
him off to comple for the love of God
she needs somebody blow this man
for I call sex draw okay you ready sex
draw no this way oh Jordan close your
eyes to much sex talk can everybody see
Jordan don't peek did you just feel a
poke on your right forearm yes did
everyone see me do that yes Simon Ian
still shook from Bill Murray you ped
mine right yeah did everyone see me do
that
show us on Jord where they touched you
her eyes are closed you peeking all
right I need to ask you a question her
eyes are closed I want you to tell
everybody right now what happened what I
do to you you poked my right forearm no
after that you brushed my the top of my
nose
oh my God messing with me right now was
that wi hold on hold on hold on do you
feel that my CES circles
clockwise sorry eyes eyes what tilt your
head up look at her eyes she is not
peeking I want to know when do you have
read receipts on your text no I never
touch them Simon is sweating Superman's
about to rip that off Jordan no peeking
okay how
about suck me off real quick yeah yeah
yeah in the name of magic did you feel
anything yet no how about right now
anything no my theory is that the moment
I do something to Sam it goes through
his hand I don't know why he's wearing
this gloves goes all the way over to her
do Jordan Open Your Eyes Open Your Eyes
Open Your Eyes what did you just feel
something right here oh oh my
God what the hell's going
on his nose and his chin this is voodoo
no no no no no anyone can do that do it
all right now we got to do Rex Rex is
having a mental breakdown over close
your eyes all right ready here okay so
uh yes Jordan and Sam hold hands okay
Sam shut your eyes shut your eyes Sam
okay so Simon's still upset okay and uh
whoa Jew Jew beard over here he's crazy
okay he is still think about Bill Murray
marks G okay now Jordan here here I was
on AGT here
now Sam I did not touch you your eyes
are closed what did you just feel on
your face something in my ear yes it
eyes close to the ear you should have
just that was kind of close to the ear
no because what I was feeling wasn't a
tingle it was a direct paper on my face
it was I did guess damn it he guessed
you don't have the powers
fcking you know who's the best at bits
thank you but who's second best Tod
glass dude yeah he's the best I've had
him on a couple times bit episodes he's
he's just for him it's about it is about
the bit he his the hardest I've ever
laughed is him and Rory Scoville I was
on a train going from London to
Amsterdam I was in all like a math
equation and there's a train going the
from Amsterdam to London go on with fem
anir and David Spade what was the
conductor's name the conductor had
a120 okay all in dimes when people give
riddles you go like this okay like
you're trying to catch something do you
think there's people who do what we do
but in riddles how cool would that be
like if you got up and you were a riddle
guy and you were like all right you had
a big crowd you're like here's the
riddle you do it and you just watch
people go I got it and you're like and
then almost you could do they have
riddle guys yeah but he's a
villain there's ma magic dudes are
pretty good they're like riddle guys
almost I'm talking about the Riddler oh
I'm really good at riddles are you
really yeah I think it's because I took
riddlin when I was in third grade and I
got off it right away so like it didn't
consume me but it's still part of me but
I'm really good at riddles I was really
oh by the way really quick I just want
to let you know in case you're going to
ask the horses name is
Friday when I release my podcast I'm
about to release a podcast too what's it
going to be called the Chad Hank
show are you [__] kidding
me are you upset about that yeah I mean
it's just you're like stealing like my
my whole [__]
dude is this called the Adam fredland
show yeah it is actually maybe you read
your [__] mug dude apparently you
didn't take reading at Northwestern you
took [__] you [__] acting and
getting not white
[__] this isn't a podcast luckily this
is a talk show so there's not that it's
not that similar you [__] stepping in
my [__] dude I'm going to I'm going to
make [__] I'm going to start a
workout
program yeah it's called [__] get a
body like
mine yeah and it includes uh being
called Gay on the internet for the last
seven years how does that make you feel
good it's pride month all right your
final bucket pole of the night goes by
the name of Heath cordz everybody here
we go we're going to finish it strong 60
seconds
uninterrupted by Heath cordz everyone
here we go here comes
Heath oh [__] okay [__] yes make some
[__] noise for Heath corz
everybody
[Applause]
on I feel
like I feel like I'm the opposite of a
pedophile
[Applause]
I'm 21 years old but on on the outside
I'm just a little
boy and that's because For Me growing Up
puberty was a lot like my father
absent and so I get asked about my age
all the time how old are you how old are
you no I'm not selling you f and all how
old are
[Laughter]
you and it gets annoying having to
answer this question all the time so
over the years I've started to have fun
with it and I sometimes tell people that
I was never
born and that I have been present
through all of what has been and what
will
[Applause]
be ticket see I came into existence
before the Earth and stars and I will be
here on the day they fall because I am
ageless but yet old
enough to [__] your
[Applause]
mother comedy podcasting stats from
October Mike feny made the most guest
appearances last month going on eight
total podcasts including the Tim Dylan
show kill Tony only fans you know what
dude Being Ian with Jordan stuff Island
the Josh Potter show and the J train
podcast the top three most viewed
episodes from last month starts off with
flagrance episode featuring Dylan danis
at 2.7 million views in second place we
have sexy red on this past weekend which
currently stands at 1.5 million followed
by Adam ry's Dr Phil and Sam Talent on
kill Tony at 1 . 4 million views be sure
to subscribe to joke world right now if
you enjoyed this monthly recap and want
to stay in the comedy Loop and to truly
never miss anything happening with all
of your favorite comedians tune in to
our weekly comedy news show which you
can find on the end screen right after
this also one last thing before we go if
you're interested in claiming your free
joke World stickers go check out the
link in our description right now go to
our Instagram click the link in that bio
and we have a form that you can fill out
we'll mail you these in the mail for
free thank you so much for
watching at joke
world that's did it joke
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out